this is Startalk what is gravity
fundamentally made up of is it a result
of some quantum phenomena or is there
any particle responsible for gravity how
fast do the gravitational waves travel
through space and what decides the limit
of that speed a lot of questions I love
it when people cuz that sounds like they
were burning within him and he couldn't
get to sleep sleep at night to get him
off his chest I love pacing
I love it so so gravity before quantum
by the Einsteinian gravity was conceived
before quantum mechanics was discovered
so Einstein gravity's 1916 this is where
matter curved space and objects respond
to that curvature that's what we call
gravity when quantum physics came in
where everything was accountable as a
particle wave duality if you have
something that our gravity waves
Einstein predicts the existence of
gravity waves then there ought to be a
particle counter part to that gravity
wave we think when we say we'll call it
gravitons just the same way any
particles any matter at all will have a
wave version of it from a quantum
mechanical point of view so a gravity
waves were predicted to move at the
speed of light in Einstein's equations
and if you have a graviton the
propagator of gravity of gravity that
would also move at the speed of light so
there you have it
but now we've never detected a graviton
well we or directly have we detect nor
have we directly detected gravity waves
but we have top people working on it is
the laughs the laser interferometric
gravitational wave observatory shortened
to LIGO is a multi location Observatory
that uses high-technology
lasers and interferometers where it
knows the distances between two points
and long tunnels accurate to like the
width of the nucleus of an atom so
that if a gravity wave comes across and
it slightly jiggles the space between
these two measured points it will
measure it it will know it and that will
be would become the first detection of a
gravity wave passing across us so what
makes gravity waves when gravity changes
somewhere in the galaxy so if you have
two stars orbiting and then they collide
then there's a ripple in the
gravitational wave continuum that's out
there and that's what you would then see
if a star plunges into a black hole
these are disturbances in the
gravitational field and those
disturbances are the gravity waves that
get measured so we got top people
working out we've never measured them
but they predicted to exist not only
from Einstein's special gravity a
general theory of relativity his theory
of gravity but also from quantum physics
so we can detect but not measure did I
understand well we can detect the
existence of gravity okay but the
graviton that propagates it to know that
that is a particle the gravity wave that
tells us when something got disturbed in
the universe
those have yet to be directly detected
we have indirectly detected
gravitational energy by two pulsars
orbiting one another they have such high
gravities at their surfaces and you
orbit them near one another that there
that system is unstable it radiates
gravitational energy okay and if you
were aiding gravitational energy then
the system's orbits closer today than it
did yesterday and as it keeps doing it
they orbit closer and closer and closer
and they eventually just collide the
measurement of binary pulsars giving up
the gravitational ghost led to a Nobel
Prize in Physics Joe Taylor and Russell
hulls Russell Holtz was one of the Bronx
High School of Science his eighth Nobel
laureates nice yes
that's as many as the country of Spain
by the way I know that's out that's
that's crazy Wow
and I now feel more prepared for that
category on Jeopardy okay
you